[Music]
a yellow Roth is a legend you all know
this but I know him from a gym called
crunch
he's legendary to me in many other ways
do you know that I got kicked out of
that crunch for not wearing underwear
wait what yes it's a gym in West
Hollywood run by gay men and I used to I
was poor and I had these like umbros
remember Ambrose shorts and I didn't
wear underwear with I don't know I just
didn't wear underwear when I worked out
I guess and I would do sit-ups were you
doing the leg machine when you open your
legs the thigh machine and then I did an
auditions back then oh it was the Sharon
Stone track but I was um uh uh remember
there was mirrors I would do sit-ups in
the mirror in the mirror and they asked
me to leave
and the jokes on them because I never
paid for my membership ha ha I would go
through and uh I'm not gonna say punch
lines if that's how you laugh no I'm
just saying the jokes on them was that a
punch line I'm not saying haha I'll
laugh when there's a bunch line again no
end to the story can we turn on that
oven please because at this point it's
preferable no by the way this by the way
this is my horror movie This Is My
Nightmare this is first of all the
crunch was amazing because it would be
you me Mindy Kaling like Chris Jericho
it was a fun fun bunch and Whitney we
were doing Jennifer Carpenter oh yeah
Jennifer Carpenter and then remember I
don't know if you were there at the time
this is when I was kind of like early
early I think before we had met because
like you know uh Eli and I've been
friends for how long a long time never
tried anything on me it's actually
insulting
um oh by the way hold on instant friends
instant friends but you could say but I
never tried anything I knew except I
told everyone do you want to tell it so
there's something called IMDb which is
the mass Master database for every this
is actually this is before Twitter so
the only way before every meeting I went
on I went on my IMDb trivia and I loaded
all these ridiculous things is
definitely allergic to cats can't stand
the sight of blood was cut in half of
the chainsaws Bar Mitzvah because I knew
the journalists were so lazy that before
they met with you they'd print out your
IMDb trivia or before a meeting and
people would be like so you are you
allergic to cats and what's this thing
about the fair book so that I could
create my own myths that every story
you're socially engineering the journal
is to write about go on my IMDb now
they're still there it's like but would
you never go with it when they brought
it up oh I knew that they hadn't done
their homework and I could just say
whatever I wanted I could craft my own
narrative so I went on but then I
realized you could do it to other people
so I real I knew that when Whitney was
going to have meetings people would
print out her IMDb before she walked in
the room like who's this girl I don't
know what is she doing look her up on
IMDb then you click trivia and get
engaged to Eli Ross was briefly engaged
to director Eli Roth okay and then
because we were gonna go see A Very Long
Engagement that was going to be like and
because we'd seen Amelie and then A Very
Long Engagement came out we never got to
see it so we did a very I wrote was
briefly engaged to director Eli Roth but
this is like Cabin Fever time so it's
it's such it's not crazy enough it's
like oh they totally could that could
have been yeah but you couldn't get rid
of the why like we couldn't
get how bad of an actor actress is
Whitney that she's engaged to Eli Roth
and in none of his movies that part I
didn't think through yeah
she like Roth and I'd be like well I
don't want to call him a liar because he
like as a you know I don't want to fuck
up his life and like you know and then I
was like well yeah and I just I didn't
really do her like it's not for me like
I didn't yeah embarrassing it was I
didn't even get the job to get the knife
in my pussy on the trampoline oh you
could yeah
well you know vendula bednarova who I
did cast did a fantastic job she was you
know a Czech porn star anyways and then
we won
um uh uh and then oh yeah because I
would go in and they'd be like so you're
engaged you like rock no no no you told
me they would soon they'd be like so
you're like you'd be like one they'd be
like
how's Hollywood made some friends and um
you were are you you're not married
right no what but you were oh by the way
I didn't know about it
I'd be like what are you talking about
and they just thought I was fucking nuts
I'd be like no I haven't been engaged to
anyone like they just thought I was a
liar to try to flirt with other
producers because a lot of times women
that are married will pretend they're
single so like this bitch is like
cheating on Eli what an asshole it was
so great and then they were like you're
engaged into Eli you're like haha you
guys my friend like what did Eli tell
you that they're like no it's on the
internet yeah it's like a paranoid
schizophrenic
psychopath it was like pretty good thing
I wasn't but the thing about it was we
also were like we were on best week no
like he's my friend we're friends like
he like all like black guys weird no but
I'll date you if you're interested like
I was like it looked like I was trying
to be single for male producers exactly
it was it couldn't have it worked so
much better it was like that joke paid
dividends like I could never have
planned but the best thing was see
Whitney and I were friends we were also
briefly on a TV show called best week
ever because she was like a comedian and
I was the director but I knew the
producers of Fred Graver someone's like
just come to Best Week Ever I forgot
about it so we would go and do best week
ever and see each other and they'd give
you a list of topics the day before so
that morning you'd write because you're
for some fucking reason I know there's
lots of overlaps in comedy and horror
which we'll talk about it in a minute
but you're also and it it pains me to
say this hilarious thank you Whitney
but we would jokingly be competitive and
be like did you say that joke about you
know whatever that Britney Spears
Christina Aguilera you know whatever
Lindsay Lohan whatever was the thing of
like 2000 when we were discussing a
bunch of uh uh teenagers
well you didn't know back then it was a
joke the only source was teams so they
would give you like what had ever
happened that week because it was
pre-social media so the joke was wow
look we're doing a TV show what happened
this week how funny is that yeah like
the concept itself is funny so but we
would be on the treadmill and we would
talk and then we would watch the show
and be like you had two jokes we were we
were like jokingly competitive about it
because we knew we didn't care but I was
like I should have said that joke they
thought we were engaged maybe and then
so I was like I was like oh I have a
great joke and then because and then it
worked and then but then I had to like
write IMDb like 15 times I was like I
will try and take it off I was like I I
literally had to write and like do stuff
with IMDb be like please take this off
Whitney's things I did it like it's
actually embarrassing now it's become
like the the herpes of IMDb trivia
now is she famous like the joke's over
let's let it yeah yeah I don't want
anyone thinking I can't get any girls
today it's not it's not there anymore
yeah everyone thinks it was engaged and
by the way were you there at the time
that Jody Foster uh uh Jeff Goldblum was
on the elliptical and Jody Foster came
in and got next to him and I was like I
thought all celebrities like just I
thought they all talked to each other
and they never spoke it was so weird
it's weird when you see that interaction
you just assume that like but the way
our parents do the way my mom as soon as
I was in Hollywood they'd be like I saw
an article with your friend Bruce Willis
I was like this is her on campus I was
like I don't know Bruce Willis but I
know he was a famous person in Hollywood
but then you know then I wound up
working with him later they're like see
he's your friend I'm like still not we
worked but that's everything like if I
was a PA I remember as a PA on quiz show
which dates me whoa on quiz show
assistant to the producer and Ray finds
and my mom starts sending me GQ Magazine
with Ray fines on the cover I was like
what are you doing what's your friend
Ray fines I was like Mom I was assistant
to producer I have one of a hundred
people working the movie I said good
morning to him but I don't collect
magazines the same thing with like my
mom would be like you know Ryan Gosling
had a restaurant he had a Moroccan
restaurant when he first like Ryan when
he was Indie actor before his heartthrob
he had a Moroccan restaurant that was
like off La Cienega or Robertson and he
would go in the kitchen and cook like
that was his thing he was he would only
do like Art House movies he worked in a
bodega like Ryan was like super funny
weird and interesting he's like we're
like why are you working in Bodega he's
like because I like it I like talking to
people then he had a restaurant and then
so we I took like my parents we went to
the Moroccan restaurant and Ryan Gosling
comes and I'm like this is Ryan
Gosling's restaurant my mom's like what
are you talking about I mean he comes
out of the kitchen and then she's like
he's so nice he's so nice so then it
started with like how's how's your
friend Ryan Gosling I'm like well he's I
don't know I I don't really hang out
with him but we have hung out he's a
nice guy in him my mom starts sending me
every article ever on Ryan Gosling for
like four years and I was like we have
to and of course I tell Ryan this I was
like Ryan if you ever want all of your
breasts
I have a buddy he's like and so of
course I run into Ryan Gosling at some
event that my parents are at and Ryan
goes like extra nice to my mom going oh
you're so so and she's like see your
friend Ryan Gosling and Ryan and Ryan is
like a wedding of you and Whitney
Cummings for months and then Ryan would
be like yeah now you're gonna get on for
the rest of the next six years
it's a joke it's like but that's what
parents do they love that they're like
oh your friend like Hollywood is one big
friend because everybody gets along in
Hollywood nobody is not friends with
people sure I wanted to look up Eli's uh
IMDb facts because oh my God they're
good yeah they're all they're on there I
don't know what's going on trivia I
don't see trivia anymore I feel like uh
I'm Gonna Be Quick on like my birthday
and then it goes to trivia they keep
reading okay good good uh April 18th
Boston Massachusetts whatever the first
four hour because it's in order of when
you did them so they're like literally
20 years old when I started I feel like
they don't have fun oh trivia okay let's
see one Student Academy Award in 1995
NYU film thesis restaurant dogs spend
six years researching the project uh for
director David Lynch that's true it's
true right okay I got the idea for Cabin
Fever when he was in Iceland and
contracted yeah and contracted a case of
a flesh eating disease I remember it was
a skin infection I exaggerated for IMDb
it was it wasn't you know advertising
fasciitis or photobacterium damzela it
was just looking kind of ringworm but I
did shave and take off like all my skin
and I was scratching and got like chunks
on my face yeah that's what it looked
like but of course what as soon as that
happens and I'm scratching and holding
my looking my hand it's an exact scene
in the movie like that and and then I
look in the mirror I was like where's
the camera and then I went to a doctor
in Iceland this is 1991. I was working
on a horse farm training Icelandic
horses what crying in a horse you
trained horses yeah I mean I didn't know
what I was doing but they taught me I
helped out for nine weeks I lived on the
farm riding breaking and training
courses Icelandic horses and then I had
a horse at this Farm English
yeah no I know like I really got into
writing and I signed the courses and
living in ice that's a whole Iceland
theme in Hostel and in Hostel too you
can see me in Hustle too riding through
the frame on my Iceland of course can I
say something to you yes um because I do
you know Equine Therapy for you know
with average Youth and um you know kids
with autism and you know kids that were
abused and rehabs and stuff like that
and because so much communication is
non-verbal people learn so much from
just like you know being with horses and
communicating with horses because if you
say what you mean uh or if you're
basically if you're feelings uh and your
body language contradict they get very
confused like has did working with
horses and training horses help you as a
director uh be able to be like a better
leader like like from that experience
and how much you can communicate uh just
with your body language and your energy
because I think a lot of times people
don't realize that even when they're not
talking they're communicating and their
energy is coming off and you know when
someone comes in a director comes in and
it's like ever it sets the tone as soon
as you walk in even if you're like hey
guys great day let's go I'm sorry
everyone's like what's going on you know
how contagious our energy is and horses
feel that because they're prey animals
so they kind of hold up a mirror to
where your energy is any of this yeah I
got the flesh thing in my face and I was
like let's make a good hormone
those from the hay in the barn so yeah
your leaders the leadership came from
being a camp counselor like that's where
I got the idea for sybians to sit and on
and videos
the three Summers that I was a camp
counselor at Meadowbrook Day Camp when I
had a group of 35 to 40 10 and 11 year
old boys and you got to go to archery
and arts and crafts you can change from
swimming and I know he took your chair
but let me tell you something just sit
in this chair for now and I'm going to
give you an extra cookie but you can't
tell them because we're in the special
cookie club right because yeah okay
that's our secret right organizing those
kids I had them wrapped around my finger
and then it was like I know he got a
bigger trailer but but your trailer his
Trail is bigger but it's actually gross
and yours has a better toilet and the
blah blah blah blah I know that they
like you think I'm shooting the close-up
of what you don't realize is that you're
the scene that they're you're not in I'm
gonna get a close-up of you there and
that's right those skills of and I was
like the neighborhood babysitter I was
like the kid that was responsible the
parents trusted those are the skills
that it paid off directing because I
couldn't believe it I was like oh my God
this is like being a fucking camp
counselor because you are responsible
for 20 adults that are probably being
run by their inner child because
everyone recreates their childhood
circumstances over and over and over
this is also why I love okay so that's
genius also this is why I like uh hiring
moms because usually when there's like a
problem like is anyone do you need a
water do you want to go take a nap can I
tell you it's true I love it it's really
great when you have the actors that have
kids and there's a problem on set and
the parent comes out it's just like all
right you can really see that right away
that reminds me but but with the horses
what was amazing was and this is like
when I swam the Sharks and the like I I
had a similar experience I would go out
into the pen I'd never done this there
were like 40 or 50 Icelandic horses and
they were in this pen and you would walk
out into the pen and there they in
America they start training the horses
at like two years old they start
breaking them they wait until they're
five or six in Iceland so they call them
spirited they're like much more
developed personalities by the time you
start training them and teaching them
the gates and stuff so the ones that are
four or five that you walk out they come
right up to you and start nuzzling you
you're surround founded by these animals
and they're short and they have sloping
backs and long hair because it was you
know it was getting ready for the
summertime it was still cold you just
hug them and they would come up to you
and nuzzle you and without knowing their
names or seeing the difference in the
colors you knew who everyone was they
had such strong personalities and this
one is shy and this is the friendly one
and then this is this one and this one's
mad at that one and being there for nine
weeks
every day you just look forward to the
moment when you're out there with those
animals and I swear to God I had that
experience with sharks and I was totally
convinced shark's gonna kill you they're
going to be monsters they're going to
eat you and I went down underwater and I
found them to be the most like very like
shy intelligent careful like looking at
me if you had a piece of fish they would
carefully take it out of your hand like
very conscious to not hurt you not like
I mean it was what if it's me on my
period though nothing I cut my hand open
blood that could care less they don't
they don't like human blood you cut open
a fish they're like oh that's they want
they they're not we're not in their food
chain so if you're on your period or
anything it's like orangutan you might
get raped shark nothing's gonna happen
Dolphins like to force themselves on
people okay well Dolphins okay dogs are
different but sharks are not like I was
like What if I cut my hand the girl's
like what if I have my period they're
like you're fine don't worry you'll see
and I did it like I was I realized that
I'd cut my hand on some coral and I was
bleeding and there was nothing from the
Sharks and I was wait I'm actually with
a cut hand waving it in front of a
shark's nose nothing but so did was it a
slow build up to being that confident
instantaneous I went down first I went
with reef sharks in the Bahamas and were
very shallow and they told me and then
they were and I was like okay I want to
go in Tahiti and I dove with tiger
sharks
and the Tigris with these you know two
thousand pounds I mean 18-foot creatures
that come right over you like the
opening of star and they were I mean you
could put your hand on their nose I mean
we had someone I look I have people
around me that were very experienced I
could tell by the fins whether this
one's of course they took an hour the
thing is you have like 45 minutes or an
hour of air
and it takes like an hour for them to
get close because they're so shy so it's
really that last 10 minutes when your
air is this low that the shark is really
comfortable around you you can't if you
blow bubbles the shark runs away because
they're like what is this can I ask you
a question that's interesting like
what's the biological basis of them
being shy because they don't have any
predators do they no they're apex
predators but they their energy it takes
a lot for them to go after a fish
they're biologically they're oldest
creatures in the planet they're older
than trees 400 million years old they've
been around they're evolved to be such
sharp Hunters their job in the ocean is
to to eat sick and dying fish so when
we're splashing around sick and dying
fish I saw what if my pussy smells like
sick and dying fish well
they're gonna they might go after that
they might but they might just be like
this is too much let this one go let
this whatever this is hard pass let it
go extinct no they they um but they but
I saw seals hanging onto the back of
their tails and like that's why there's
little fish where Mora is eating their
teeth and eating the scraps around them
they can't catch the healthy fish it's
also energy conservation because they're
scavengers they don't want to waste a
bunch of animals they're gonna eat once
a month once every couple weeks so
they're like waiting and they have a
social hierarchy when they're going for
a seal they're like down there deciding
who goes next they like they do what's
called mouth gaping where they're like
Jaws move or they're communicating I
watch great whites they're like and like
moving their fins they're all talking to
each other they have a system you're
going to go here you're gonna go that
and they look at you are you predator or
prey and we're large and we have when
you're under the water with them it's
like where when you're at the surface
splashing like is that a fish and they
bite and they let go but now that's why
I made my documentary fin because enough
to be too depressing but we're killing
yeah the low estimate is 100 million but
I think now it's 250 million a year but
wait we are doing it or in the world
everyone because like the shark fin soup
and I think people are afraid because
I'm very be I'm very I'm okay with
saying I uh uh you can criticize the
Chinese government without criticizing
the people of China like everyone's so
scared of being racist they won't even
you know say something but the shark fin
soup so uh in Asia but is this why are
we killing them we're all killing them I
mean in even in China it's the older
generation that's eating it because it's
expensive and I tried it it's basically
fishing line there's no flavor to it
it's literally fingers it's like a gummy
it's like a portobello mushroom right
nothing no it's it's string it is
fishing wire that they have to then soak
for 24 hours and Finn I go through the
process of the entire and they have a
gelatin thing that's identical imagine a
flavorless string you're wiping out the
apex predator for this this industry of
death and then they said well we can't
we can't you know
cut the fins off and throw them back but
what that did was it multiplied the
industry it made it worse because now
the shark liver oil which squalene there
is a plant replacement yep squally is
good for your face but the plant
replaces replacement you can make it out
of Olives there's like you know there's
so there's a plant squalene but they're
killing the Sharks because people are
making money off of it and there are
these rodeos look up the Alabama deep
sea fishing rodeo they're killing them
and now there's Noah which I get very
the National Oceanic atmospheric you
know Administration they are like part
of the Department of Commerce they look
at our oceans in the air
they've now are basically giving out
permits to these fishermen in Florida to
go after endangered sharks there's this
guy Robert Osborne he calls himself the
tax man he's got photos like legal eagle
motherfuckers with all these dead rare
sharks there are two fishermen if you're
going shark allies they're doing a whole
thing about this there are these two
fishermen that saw all these endangered
sharks on hooks with divers they were
divers I'm sorry they were dive on
diaper and they're like look at and they
freed them and now Noah our government
is using our tax money to send these two
fishermen to prison for five years for
destruction of federal property they're
they're actually like the fishermen have
infiltrated the government to try and
keep killing sharks I mean and these
contests are all over because there's
this uh sort of misunderstanding that
they're really violent towards humans I
think people go like oh fuck them do you
know what I mean more people six like
maybe 10 people a year die from shark
bites
too you have a higher chance of dying uh
from a TV falling in your head you have
a higher chance of dying from a vending
machine right and from a three-year-old
shooting you are armed toddlers kill
more people bees but it's like anything
I mean 100 like cigarettes are killing
about 180 000 people here it's insane
sharks are killing 10 and we're wiping
them out and then everyone's like well
good I don't want to get bitten well
there's a problem what the Sharks do is
they keep the ocean in balance and then
you'll see the mo it's like you get this
horrible like CMOS that it's basically
how to blow my brains basically the
algae blooms happen and they cover the
kelp there's kelp in the ground and and
the there's the grouper that eat the
parrot fish that like the Sharks keep
the group are out of the way so the
parrotfish basically without the sharks
around the grouper eat all the
parrotfish we eat all the algae so the
algae spread so you get this toxic algae
that we can't clean up and it blocks the
kelp which is providing half of our
oxygen like they've just found the tiger
sharks in the Bahamas which is a shark
Sanctuary there's a recent discovery
this uh scientist Austin is going to
kill me for blanking his last name he's
he's uh in tiger sharks in the Bahamas
um what they do is they keep the sea
turtle population Gallagher Austin
Gallagher thank you Austin Gallagher is
just presented this paper and it's like
a three trillion dollar Discovery
basically the sea grass that grows in
the Bahamas is eight times more powerful
at trapping carbon than the rainforest
and the only reason we know that is
because the sharks are there to keep the
sea turtles in check but without the
tiger sharks the sea turtles eat up the
grass so we would never know that
everyone's like what are we going to do
with our carbon what do we do I don't
know leave the Sharks alone and maybe
the planet can heal itself so it's also
like that there's an amazing video of
like uh uh returning the Wolves to
Yellowstone what's that it's it's the
same exact exactly that so what happens
is like if the Wolves aren't in if
there's no Predators there uh basically
the moose and the deer will over graze
in certain areas because the Wolves move
them to different places and it also
brings the rivers back it changes
exactly and then uh when there's no
grass there's no rabbits there's no
foxes there's no you know it just like
destroys Everything's changed else and
that's exactly what it is so and we're
wiping them out because the politicians
are in on it there's such greed any they
sell shark mislabeled in supermarkets
anytime you see a shark out of the water
someone's making money and everyone
every time you see a scientist that says
well sharks sharks are doing just fine
they're being paid off there's so much
money from the fishing industry that
pays for labs that the scientists are
like no the populations are doing fine
we can kill a few sharks these people
are like that's my right to kill sharks
but the Mercury there's this girl shark
girl Madison Reggie Domingo at project
knock away they do tests they test
mercury in the shark mean 32 or 33 times
higher than the allowable so if you're
even eating shark meat it's terrible for
there's no poisoning your baby you're
killing shouldn't if you're pregnant you
need to feed it your kids brain damage
the neurotoxins impotence brain damage
that are in shark that are in just the
cartilage the cartilage they scrub it
with bleach it's the most disgusting
thing it's completely inedible food
there's a plant replacement for the
liver oil the whole thing is this
industry of death and the fishing
industry is fucking terrified that
people are starting to catch on and do
you think there's like a like uh the
same way people want to do like trophy
hunting and stuff like that I know if I
use the word toxic masculinity I think
it's silly but like the idea of this
like I fucking killed a shark it's man
and women like in Florida of course
there was this contest that I was
kicking up shit on Instagram about and
this amazing woman went in an undercover
filmed it pretending to be like a
fisherman and it was like you know they
were fucking drinking beer cutting up
these rare beautiful sharks with power
saws children stabbing them with knives
with the parents drinking in the
background and the fucking footage went
around and then these people like they
were angry and they were gonna kill I
got death threats from it people were
like yeah you come to West Palm I'm
gonna fucking kill you also all my
animal rescue stuff like it's like I I I
wouldn't I had to get the giraffe out of
Malibu during the fires yeah I posted it
because it's the only way I had leverage
but like most you're dealing with
criminals so for like the Exotic Animal
trade anyone that is is traffic king
lions tigers bears there's tigers in the
back it's sex trafficking too they're
arms dealers they're Psychopaths so this
motherfucker doc antel who I'm like I
don't give a shit like I I would proudly
get murdered by you if it meant that you
would go to jail I don't give a shit but
he um yeah he's like kill the person
these are psychopaths he has also he has
on his property the Osho cult he's still
doing the Osho call shit I mean here's
the problem
you have that
everything with sharks is legal and you
can't kill these protected species so
they go to Noah Government funding and
get special permits from their buddies
to kill endangered sharks and that's how
they do it meanwhile they're like well
the sharks are just eating our fish and
then we go wait a minute during the
pandemic and during the pandemic an
additional one million boats went on the
water in Florida also if there's no
oxygen in the water you're gonna have no
fish but it's also like there you put a
million more boats in the water with
people fishing what do you think is
going to happen of course it's going to
attract more sharks so like it's not
there's no like the sharks are getting
wipes out we've lost at least 2 billion
in the last 20 years because they take
18 you know someone took 11 years to
read sexual maturity they mature like
humans they have like seven or eight
pups they're not like they lay a million
eggs and go like the the populations
won't be able to recover unless we start
this culture of like I'm starting I'm
working with shark allies and and green
for Emma to start a shark-free label
that we can go to products to like prove
you're not using Shark I mean their
vaccines and companies that are like
we're totally green there's a whole
grain washing thing of people that fake
it yeah yeah that are actually using
sharks people are like oh I don't eat
shark I don't eat this but then you
realize it's in your shampoo it's in
your mouth the cartilage the oil the
cartilage the oil and by the way GNC
sells shark cartilage pills we tested
them in the lab and they actually
inflame you they're horrible for you it
was a shark skin coach clothes terrible
it's horrible for you and then people
were like well this thing's not illegal
it's like well it doesn't mean it's not
illegal like you're waiting for a
scientist to tell you it's illegal to do
it like don't you want a future for your
kids don't you want the ocean to be not
overgrown with algae like there's like
we're talking about oceans that are
already turning to acid because they
don't they're not in balance and we're
overfishing is a general problem anyways
but fish feed two-thirds of the world so
you cancel people not to eat but it's
like Indonesia is a huge problem killing
sharks Spain they're killing sharks also
I mean I was told when I froze my eggs
uh when I was 33
um I was told by um the fertility expert
she was like do not eat fish the um from
Fukushima like all of the Power Plants
yeah yeah has it's come over here like
just don't do it yeah um I was in the
Maldives it's also you know it's just
kind of also this and I don't know if
this is I think people really want to
blame social media for everything I get
it and I understand exactly what it's
doing to our neurochemistry and neural
Pathways but however I also think that
like you know I kind of have this Theory
maybe it's just being a you know
comedian wanting to defend something
that is just like not the popular take
which is I think everything is are
always existed it just looked different
you know so it's like there's this uh
there's been a huge setback with uh
Instagram however with uh taking photos
with tigers and taking photos with oh
yeah you know what I mean so it's like
stupid shit on Instagram yeah um but uh
when I was in the Maldives you know it's
like oh we're gonna go see whale sharks
and you get to swim with them right and
we go out far far far and there was
literally 200 boats wait waiting for
this whale shark and like as soon as you
know one person knows and everyone like
starts going over there and I literally
just like started sobbing and I do
always uh SOB when I see the horse
carriages in New York like that's why I
can't live in New York when horses are
abused when horses are um I just I get
incredibly sad and uh it's like some
unfinished business or guilt or
ancestral shit with that is a different
time I mean horses animals were for work
back then there was no Machinery to do
it yeah so the concept of an animal
working was what that was the norm back
then yeah so oh I can do this is more
efficient this is what animals are I
mean we were hunting gorillas like they
were but also horses and four days you
know I have a very like
um uh hot take of like horses fought in
Wars for us we could not have won any
wars without horses they took us to the
doctor they're the only reason we have a
country in the first place like they I
mean slaves and horses built this
country you know and black people get it
you know remember when uh Snoop Dogg uh
was uh commenting on the Olympics and
some guy one uh uh gold for dressage and
he's like I think the horse did the work
you know what I mean it's like there's
just this all animals are for our
benefit yeah when what really pisses me
off is we're kind of superficially at
the top of the food chain like if it
wasn't for guns opposable thumbs and
like cages and stuff like we would not
be you know have the ascendancy that we
have you know so but there's just no
um that's why I mean zoos like you know
I was talking to psychiatrists about it
because um you know I'm anti-zoo for a
lot of reasons I know a lot of zoos want
to say that they're helping save the
species stuff like that it's bullshit
it's not true
um and uh uh when kids go to zoos at a
young age they learn oh these big
powerful beautiful things are for my uh
basically uh benefit like they you know
and then they grow up to essentially
treat employees like that women like
that it's just like everything is here
for me to exploit essentially and they
say that it starts with Zeus that's
really interesting I mean the problem is
you know where else are they going to
live now their natural Wildlife is just
being decimated by us you still have
people in Asia they're paying for these
animals I mean Dior is still making like
rare crocodile bags disgusting they're
people that will and by the way they
still have thousands and thousands of
bears in boxes just to get their
gallbladder they were because they think
their gallbladder is like the titoaba
trade they were like what 14 of the much
Steve Shadows they're like the title was
more valuable than cocaine people have
been like five hundred thousand dollars
to have like a fish bladder Because by
the way Ivory is still on the list of
things to get your uh spouse on an
anniversary you know it's like first is
gold diamond and then like you're 18 is
Ivory yeah no it's crazy I mean we're
just driving everything to Extinction
and it'll be gone for our our kids
Generations it's it's really horrible
when did you first feel in your heart
this is a mission I'm gonna fight for
well I was really weirdly Jaws obsessed
um we should probably pull up the poster
for Finn yes please yes Discovery plus
with me or the trailer but I was weirdly
Jaws obsessed and uh that's not weird I
mean everyone was we all were yeah and
and because the grouping in
Massachusetts and swimming and sharks
are monsters and then
um I actually ran into someone who's
running Discovery at the time Discovery
Channel and he's like do you want to
host shark after dark because I'd done
this thing where we recreated the
Milgram experiments for the show called
curiosity right like the shocking people
so Discovery knew me and they were like
oh Eli is like a good personality he's
smart he's fun and sort of my horror
background went well with it and then
Eli and horror and sharks and I was like
of course and then they said they're
like we'll send you on a dive so I knew
Lori Goldberg was the head of publicity
do you want to do a dive in the Bahamas
we'll take you we'll do the whole thing
so I went I was like this is the
greatest experience of my life and so I
then I started interviewing people and
they were like yeah it's too bad we're
losing 100 million a year and it's like
2016. I was like what are you talking
about they're like yeah 2015 like we're
losing 100 million sharks a year I'm
like how's that even possible and so
then year after why isn't the front page
news all the time conversations there's
a reason the fishing industry wants you
to be afraid of sharks and the same
emotionally engineered to hate them and
the same way that yeah the horse
carriages have been glamorized with like
English movies and romance and and yeah
tiger shark let's pull up the uh poster
for Finn please yeah there's one yeah
Michael Mueller just look up the fin
post Michael Mueller did it yeah no yeah
Michael Mueller does incredible work
with sharks also uh horses I was
shooting horses you know with a Taliban
I know Mueller came on as an EP I went
diving and with great whites with
Mueller he's incredible I mean his by
the way Michael Molly's VR series into
the now just dropped on Mana Quest the
headsets and I'm in it you can see me
and Mike Michael Mueller diving with uh
sharks can you watch it if it's not on a
headset somewhere yeah he said it's on
his Instagram just put it on oh great
because I just did a VR project
um that is out now when is this podcast
gonna drop um like a two weeks okay
because yeah it came out now it's the
21st fantastic is when it came out it's
uh it's called trick or treat with
Vanessa Hudgins I did like a VR haunted
house with her and like you go in
Horizon worlds where you're like in a
theater with other people and it's also
a standalone so to me with a tiger shark
yeah that's Fancy with the shark coming
up that makes me want to kill myself but
we gotta address it break
hey brunch you pour over
little lists of over so why not do the
same when you're booking a doctor at a
doctor's appointment makes no sense with
ZocDoc you can see real verified patient
reviews to help find the right doctor
we've all been to the wrong doctor the
right one in your network and in your
neighborhood after all finding the right
doctor is just as if not more important
than finding the right plate of eggs
benedict get your priorities straight
kiddos
um ZocDoc is a miracle because God I
mean the fact that we used to call a
doctor's office when we already have the
UTI or the gal or the you know corn or
hammer toe
I'm not listing the personal things I
need to go to a doctor for I swear like
we would have to call and you don't it's
impossible to make a doctor's
appointment without Zack talk you call
and they're always at lunch they're on a
two and a half hour break they open at 9
30 they close at 11 30 for a break and
then they close at 3 30. after that like
it's you can the stress that is like
caused by booking a doctor is probably
what's creating the disease I need the
doctor to fix not suck doc solves all
your problems and takes the stress off a
ZocDoc is a free app it shows you
doctors who are patient reviewed not
self-reviewed they take your insurance
and are available when you need them who
needs a doctor after they've already had
the thing okay I don't need you to tell
me my appendix burst
why didn't you see me two weeks ago like
I needed you to
on ZocDoc you can find every specialist
Under the Sun whether you're trying to
straighten those teeth fix an achy back
get that mold checked out I think some
of you really need to I've I went to
Starbucks and there were a couple people
in tank tops and I am telling you get to
zoc Doc ASAP those do they look very
irregular uh you can go to ZocDoc for
anything it has you covered stock Doc's
mobile app is as easy as ordering a ride
at a restaurant or getting delivery to
your house search fine and book doctors
with only a few Taps instead of Taps on
the knee with a stupid triangular mini
hammer that does absolutely nothing find
and review doctors read verified patient
reviews from real people who made real
appointments now when you walk into that
doctor's office you're all set to see
someone in your network who gets you go
to zocdoc.com to find I feel like this
should be a dating app
just saying just saying if you're
meeting this many doctors in your area
oh wow zocdoc.com find the right doctor
that is right for you and book an
appointment in person or remotely that
works for your schedule every month
millions of people use doc doc and I am
one of them it's my go-to whatever I
need to find or book a quality doctor
asap go to zocdoc.com I use ZocDoc when
I had the um baby raccoon run over my
foot and I had to get a uh rabies
vaccine
they were available within an hour I
mean they were surprised they're very
they're like we have not had to give a
rabies shot in our entire practice uh
and then I had to try to get what are
they the the the the because what are
the things that are the antibody Monte
Carlo antibodies for that like they were
just so nice about it they were so
available you can't like wait three
weeks to get in for a rabies scare like
you got you have like two hours so
um I was very grateful that this existed
go to zocdoc.com Whitney and download
the ZocDoc app for free then start your
search for a top-rated doctor today many
are available within 24 hours that zoc
zoc doc doc.com slash Whitney zocdoc.com
Whitney so I went into one of the Sharks
and I was like oh my God they're like
dogs they personally and what happened
was they're like yeah this one that had
this joke or smile they're like oh
that's so-and-so that's Lucy the shark
if you look up divers shark ass divers
for help this shark they're like that's
Lucy I'm like what do you mean Lucy like
Lucy came to us with a hook in her mouth
about three months ago and the two girls
that I was with that were diving they
went and they saw this shark was coming
up them with a hook and following them
so the next dive one girl had a knife
and the shark came up let her go up cut
the hook and the shark was so happy
swimming around followed the group and
she was with us and we fed her and there
I was hand feeding her and like yeah she
doesn't want to leave I was like so the
shark knew that you guys had hands and
could take a hook out of its mouth and
they're like yeah and then so I went in
the water with just like first I did
with soup where I was like you know just
hey and I was like Chum me so that the
Sharks were all around me like join me
and then I went underwater with scuba
with them and I hand fed them and I was
like this is my happy place I was so Zen
with them and then in Tahiti I don't
just started diving around the world
with sharks but you can see there's less
and less and less and less you know you
go to tiger Beach and they were like
yeah 10 years ago this place was filled
now there's because they travel around
the world they're just getting killed
then they're getting and then you look
up Alabama deep sea fishing rodeo on
Facebook you look at these photos and
you have the sponsors are I Heart Radio
Coca-Cola these motherfuckers are
killing in danger they're like killing
great hammer heads and I put the shit on
my Instagram there's like kids like five
kids on top of wait who are the other
sponsors I'm gonna oh I heart racing
Bridges Coca-Cola I mean it's just
amazing look up look up and then they
put up a whole thing because of me they
were like our scientists have assured us
that this is totally sustainable and
we're not doing anything bad for the
ecosystem with just it's these
motherfuckers it's like this guy's paid
off but I see exactly the radio
Chevrolet yep and by the way and by the
way I have um uh umbrella insurance so
no one can see me some guy
came who's a bear hunter said why don't
we bring back sharks this year and they
brought back killing and a great
Hammerheads like well they're not in
danger it's like well they're threatened
it doesn't matter if the whole shark if
the whole ocean was filled with every
shark why are you killing them their
function is to keep the ocean clean they
are the doctors of the ocean that is
their job and the oh I mean it's just
like insanity that we're killing them
for nothing so I made a move I spent
five years making this movie can I ask
you a question about uh Blackfish uh
changed that yeah like Sea World they
are all slowly like there's ones that
are grandfathered in it's very tricky to
bring one of them back into the wild who
cares
um but uh that actually came from a kid
in school who said uh they were like oh
we're gonna go to Sea World and she's
like I won't go there like she would
kids know before they go the kids know
they know this is really something's
wrong there's yeah and I'm doing um the
Lisa Frank animated show and it's about
this exact thing a kid that Witnesses
and tries to free you know kids are like
why are we killing them yeah sure like
this is wrong this feels wrong like and
uh but uh The Cove which is about the
you know Dolphins then still of course
was involved like I'm not totally sure
like I can't tell you the exact impacts
of it but like these documentaries are
what changed things but do you know what
it's money it's a hundred percent money
and that people won't spend their money
at Sea World anymore that's why that's
right because it's not cool guess what
you can't post it on Instagram people go
why are you there that's why what's
wrong with you and guess what how about
the Mitsubishi Corporation
is killing all of the tuna in the world
to own it
everyone's like wait what yeah your
television your Mitsubishi car they're
cornering the market on bluefin tuna and
freezing it
so that no one can have it and they have
it and you have to buy it from them and
it'll be incredibly expensive Japan
is fucking killing they are blocking
protecting the bluefin tuna because
Mitsubishi is paying them this is so
fucking corrupt and Noah
should be fucking defunded these
motherfuckers and look on shark allies
and they're doing it's a whole position
to help we tried to do a GoFundMe to
help these divers who needed to raise a
hundred thousand dollars they're fucking
divers to defend themselves for three
years this is now in federal court
because Noah is fucking trying to send
him to prison for five years because
they cut the lines and set them free so
they said you're this is destruction or
property but what this really is is the
fucking fisherman in Florida have
infiltrated Noah
their friends they're now there they're
now getting on these committees so that
they want to kill the shark industry the
dive industry so they can fucking kill
them because the dive industry one shark
in its lifetime will make 250 000 in
tourism dead 30 bucks the fishermen
don't give a fuck they don't want they
see the divers there and they're like
we're trying to fish and then they're
chumming the waters and the sharks eat
our fish so let's fucking kill the
sharks so this whole charade of going
after two divers that freed endangered
fucking sharks that were permitted by
some corrupt motherfucker at NOAA for
this data we should fucking defund these
assholes and so many people feel this
way and I'm gonna go fucking off on Noah
because I have no because I'm not paid
by the fishing industry I'm part of the
movie industry so fuck you if you're
trying to go after fucking divers for
freeing endangered sharks you
motherfuckers all these fucking people
I'm gonna rally everyone to cut your
fucking funding off because I'm so angry
that you're trying to send people to
prison for freeing sharks so you're
fishing buddies your fucking buddies
that just want to wipe them out can go
fucking kill them can I ask you is to
show them on Facebook masquerade as
being like a sanctuary or like a good oh
yeah okay so they list mako shark is a
good source of protein on their site
this is disgusting okay so this is my
main deal with animal rescue stuff is
that most sanctuaries are actually worse
than Zeus yeah most sanctuaries are
complete fucking scams so I know people
see me on my Instagram like I go after
corrupt sanctuaries because those
actually do the most abuse and they're
like black by the way black tiger white
Jaguar that whole feed the real Tarzan
all those fucking Instagram feeds where
people if anyone is touching an apex
predator on land uh a lion tiger or bear
there's abuse involved so why am I
holding it what have we all learned
about female tigers and Mama bears
they're pretty protective of their
babies right so if you're holding a
tiger baby or a bear cub that room is
dead I will tell you this you know in
Mexico it's illegal to buy a jaguar it
goes by a lion it's legal by a tiger
disgusting we have there's more tigers
in captivity in Texas than in the rest
of the world it's fifteen hundred
dollars
because I've talked about this with
Eduardo they're now killing all these
coyotes the the whole Baja is all being
covered I mean coyotes are so fucking
cunning I mean the thing is about
coyotes is like you really can't kill
them because what happens is like uh
when they're um howling they're actually
taking roll call to see how many are
there so if they hear less howls the uh
mom will actually produce uh more pups
you know so that's kind of like you know
well anyways but all this stuff it's
like and by the way there are good
people the problem is there are good
people at Noah and there's people that
want to do good and I'm not like there's
not like that but like you also have a
lot of people within an organization
government money that are going to be
corrupt so I would start saying okay
defund the organization take away the
money why I want people should be
demanding why are you giving out
research permits to kill endangered
sharks what is the data you're learning
stop it I really am uh really careful
about the ones I align with because a
lot of these people are psychopaths you
know I was dealing with Wildlife weigh
station in La there's a huge problem in
LA because animals are no longer being
used in movies exotic wild animals
elephants Etc great news but that means
all these asshole animal trainers that
have 10 elephants can't make money so
they're dragging them around to birthday
parties they're selling their sperm to
the zoo and it's actually worse for them
so that movie Water For Elephants like
the actors that you probably didn't know
but they were just getting electrocuted
constantly like if it if a if uh
anything circus related if an elephant
is doing anything a lion tiger bear
elephant Dan Bilzerian fuck you
um he's also someone he's got bears at
his party because all these people that
are trainers have these really expensive
exotic animals uh Bob Dunn fuck you also
Bob Dunn procured all the animals for
Michael Jackson's uh Neverland Ranch or
whatever there's still an elephant
missing that I can't find
um uh chubs the and Bubbles that was
like four different Champs because you
can't have a pet chimp they'll rip your
face off so they would keep those um
chimps in cages so they wouldn't develop
any muscles and they were just on drugs
the whole time and then when they got
too strong they would sell them to
universities for experiments and um uh
roadside zoos in Texas I have pictures
of one of the chubs I don't have my
phone on me no I know I know I've
researched this too it's absolutely
disgusting yeah no it's horrible yeah if
if you see an animal in a movie like a
movie a music video
it is 100 a baby because after five they
kept the strength of five an adolescent
champ is on control as the strength of
five girls and a chimpanzee uh has
closer DNA to humans than the African
elephant has to the Indian elephant it's
crazy wild we are going to look back and
I mean it is it is
um disgusting the way we look back at
kids in factories in the 20s you know
it's like what we have done is like and
it absolutely is I think that and I know
this is going to sound a little fucking
you know LA but I think there there is
so much pain in the world and everyone's
at such anxiety like the fact that we
are um subjugating these animals and
looking at it all the time is adding to
this like sadness that it's very
incalculable but it's like there's just
this like I think everyone kind of feels
it you know what I mean this kind of
pain that that we're causing in the
world because it's like we're not
separate from them you know and it's
just like uh
um I think it's something that people
don't realize and they go like oh my God
uh I have such a horrible job and I just
want to go to Thailand on a vacation and
ride an elephant and you're like you
don't realize how big of a toll that's
gonna take on your own soul and your
like contract with the universe you know
I always say at the end of every show
don't write elephants the same way that
remember um Bob Barker always said spay
a new to your pets so it's like
sometimes it just takes someone having
like a just repeat thing repeat thing
which brings me to Shark Week I wanted
to ask you a Shark Week good for sharks
bad for sharks neutral should be be
highlighting more of the problem well
they've changed I mean my mission was to
help them change you know I went on it
and I think a lot of the activists that
I worked with they're like we don't do
shark week because they sell the fear
and I said well why don't we help change
that and I made the film and they just
said it was the pandemic so instead of
going for a theatrical release they said
Shark Week was short of programming and
I was like they're like let's put it on
let's air this to help like evolve the
show and they did it aired during shark
week so everyone was like there were a
lot of people that were in the
documentary that would never work with
shark week and I was like if they want
to evolve and they want to start
highlighting the problem there's 30
million people that watch these are the
people that care about sharks so let's
do it so Discovery plus so I've had a
great experience with them I found that
they you know I mean I get it like I see
I understand selling the fear I
understand the mistake but I do think
that
it builds a community and they they've
supported the documentary like crazy I
was like you know that's why people go
well Jaws is terrible for sharks and
this I was like no money is terrible for
sharks greed is terrible for sharks most
apex predators are more afraid of you
than you are of them if you get eaten by
a lion tiger bear but you did something
wrong you did something to promote them
they're not interested in you
um but also uh that's uh that is so
fascinating to me and what I do want to
say is like if you are going to go to a
sanctuary do not go to any sanctuaries
that are not gfas accredited Global
Federation of animal sanctions what do
you do about that because like in
Thailand you know that's a nightmare the
Four Seasons tented elephant camp
they're like these elephants are rescued
from the street and they buy them not
true not if it's true not if it's true
look down at their feet do they have
chains holding their feet together use
your fucking head like we are so
desperate to like get the likes and to
like touch this exotic thing I mean it's
like you know when I was uh uh my last
special before I was kind of trying to
equate like this you know me too with um
trying to figure out like I get why guys
want to
um you know touch a woman or God woman's
ass like when I'm in the airport and I
see a service dog that says service dog
do not pet I'm like if I'm like oh God
I'm gonna pet that fucking dog like I
know you know and so uh the same thing
is we we've been learned same thing with
horses people like they're like I got
bit by a horse I was like did you walk
up to it and just do this to its face
yeah it's like my French Bulldog hates
kids because the kids go right for a
face that's the thing and then I you
know I rescue people they don't they're
like is she friendly I'm like nope can I
pet her nope yeah well I told you not to
when you go and see these like and I've
seen it unfortunately but these like
leopards in boxes and and shit like that
and then their next to the sex
trafficking it's gun trafficking these
people are psychopaths and
um most of these sanctuaries are fronts
for psychopaths that are making a
ridiculous amount of money and what they
do is they um like I was in that place
in Texas that shithole when I went out
to do Rogan and I just went ape shit and
I was like filming the whole thing
because uh there were all these uh
babies and uh uh of uh lion tiger and
bear babies and they would just sell
them to Zeus they put them in the
sanctuary to get the money for you to
come to take a selfie with them and then
they just sell it to a zoo sell them for
experiments or sell them to some asshole
you know in Texas to have their own
roadside Zoo so it's like just because
it says Sanctuary like use your head
it's the same thing as like um we
couldn't get happy the elephant out of
the LA Zoo because the judge said well
my kid loves going to see happy the
elephant you know like we love you know
so it's it's a tricky thing the people
that make these laws are humans they're
like and you know I get a lot of this I
get a lot of well what about people what
about you know homelessness it's like it
start everything is programmed I I get
that all the time like why would you
care so much about yourself because the
people that do this saw it when they
were kids you know her people her people
if you see animal abuse as a kid well
the other thing is this with sharks in
particular they don't have faces
their own if you don't we don't read or
their emotions like an elephant you can
tell when it's sad a lion and a horse
and we still don't care but the but we
still don't care so imagine when you see
this thing that's like reptilian that
like whoa It's like a snake you can't
tell what it's thinking and unless
you've been in the water with that I
mean you think and like they're
beautiful it's just maybe VR people try
to see what that's like but
people are just like there's always
something more important there's always
like war or it's like too big to take on
like it's too big to be and so that's
why we say like that's exactly what the
fishing industry is banking on banking
on they love that guilt they want you to
feel small they want you to feel like
your voice doesn't matter because
they're fucking terrified and this 15
year old kid Cade safe sharks kicking up
more trouble making people freak out
this is what the comment section is for
you guys not canceling comedians yeah
like this is it go after use your voice
to go after the when you see a a
musician with a tiger in a music video I
mean someone makes a joke I had to deal
with Migos dude that was uncomfortable
you know also white tigers are all
inbred most of them are cross-eyed they
um are missing chromosomes and Sir joke
here but they're we're only two white
tigers the complete aberration so it's
only been breeding dads with daughters
and uh they're completely inbred most of
them can't see most of them can't hear
it's a real nightmare and then I post
this on my Instagram from lions tigers
and bears which is GFS gfas accredited
it's in Alpine
near San Diego it's incredible Bobby
Brink runs it she's an absolute genius
she is who remember the guy that was in
can you look this up it was at Ohio he
had 50 tigers and then someone killed
him and they all got loose yeah and then
all the police just had to shoot him
dead so she is who got the law passed
there that no uh private exotic
ownership she's absolutely fucking
gangster
um and uh where am I going with that and
why oh so what happens when uh bear uh
uh bear cubs are held and not with their
mother they're immune they don't get the
breast milk they're immune I mean they
feed him cat food it's disgusting
um and uh basically their spinal cord
doesn't develop uh properly so they walk
like really so if you go on my Instagram
it's since died but I think it was
Cherry Bomb the bear I posted this like
this is what happens when bears are held
uh you know in in whatever influencer
farms in Thailand once you see it once
you see it you can't unsee it it was
like Vietnam once uh that girl was
running from that like images can change
people's minds no one wants to hear it
well we keep saying what is the turtle
choking on the straw moment for sharks
you know like what is that thing like
when we saw the turtle truck destroy
everyone was like whoa plastic you know
can you pull up Lions Tigers and
bears.org yeah there's the video so if
you ever wait I want to talk about this
because there's an elephant
where in the room
I just made a show called my possessed
pet
kid oh let's pull that I had it on
earlier because people are watching and
they're going to be wondering why I'm
not saying anything because first of all
I will say this I found out people's
pets were possessed because I thought is
their bad possession so these are people
that love their pet it's on there's we
did four episodes on Discovery plus but
there was a girl whose horse was
possessed and they brought in an
exorcist there was a people's tarantula
was possessed and they were like Vincent
was completely different the personality
changed but the way it manifested itself
it wasn't an animal tied up to the bed
vomiting the people started
hallucinating like a demon would possess
the horse they would notice the horse
was acting weird and then they're in
their house like a demon chasing them so
it's like the Exorcist but instead of a
little girl it's a horse a dog two dogs
and a tarantula but like one guy with
his dog the dog became the master and
the guy didn't leave his house and
started he became the servant to the dog
I was so careful to make sure that like
everyone had an amazing experience I got
the people I have them with their
original pets I have the footage and we
made the scares about possession but
even so we we detailed every single
minute of the Tarantulas on set
tarantula takes a break tarantula was
loved by this like you have to like
detail minute by minute by minute even
so I'm not going to continue the show
because I love it and no one was abused
and no one was hurt but in doing the
show I realized that I'm being
hypocritical I can't be like an animal
and activist even if it's a tarantula or
a dog that someone loved and was so well
taken care of
it's it's uncomfortable like and The
Possession isn't the cat you know it's
not like a dog going nuts it's the demon
that's attacking the people in the house
I'm not going to continue it because
there's something part of me that's like
I don't feel 100 about it I love it and
Discovery was amazing and everyone had a
great experience we literally any moment
the animal is on set we film it so
there's no but still it's it's just like
what am I doing can I ask you a question
I get other ideas so I just want
everyone to know watching this that yeah
I don't think like it's I think it's an
interesting story and I was fascinated
and I went with it and we had a great
time everyone loved it awesome
experience but why even because as it
goes on you have to go more extreme I'm
not gonna do it anymore I did four it
was an idea at work but I'm not going to
continue it because I don't want to do
stuff with animals and I'm gonna say
something I don't I can't believe I've
been admitting this but
um when I find this truly happened um
when uh Tiger King came out I ever
wanted to make you know shows about Thai
people tigers and the real Tarzan you
know he had a TV deal with Will Smith
you know the guy abusing animals uh and
uh I will like take a general at that
company and go oh my God I want to do
this show about like how abusive uh
black the black uh tiger white Jaguar
guy is I want to do a show about how
abusive that uh Tarzan you know the real
Tarzan is and then they'll be like oh he
is I won't tell you what company but
he's like oh he and I'm like oh yeah I
need to do that and this is it he hears
his criminal charges and I'm going to do
like I'm not really gonna make that show
but then they stop making it interesting
you know so it's like that's kind of you
know something that I know that I you
have the power to do and I think for me
it's like what power do I have and I
think people listening probably feel
very powerless and frustrated and I'm
curious like if you're you have a dream
what someone listening to this would do
right now in terms of an action for
sharks like what would it be oh I mean
first of all going into GNC and saying
why are going on their social media and
please stop selling shark products going
after Alabama deep sea fishing rodeo and
Target every sponsor and go please why
pay make sure demand that the fishing
rodeo they're not your sport Catch and
Release to when you drag a shark 40
miles an hour behind a boat
doesn't matter if it's for 10 minutes or
an hour the stress hormone like like
this the Hammerhead will be dead when
you put it back in the water unless
you're a marine biologist and you know
how to study sharks and you can humanely
take it out for a scientific purpose at
a university to lab
for something dragging an animal pulling
an animal up most of those animals die
they're intelligent animals on a hook
being traumatized pulled up people take
photos with them and they're dumped back
in and they're dead they drown so I
would say go on shark allies and look at
our petition shark allies is amazing
we're doing a whole thing a future with
sharks go on a future with sharks.com
it'll take you to shark allies and start
we're going to start using our voice
with the petitions to like make Noah to
stop stop giving out research permits to
these monsters to go after the fishing
tournaments like there's this guy you
know there's a whole thing in Florida
they're trying to do a Statewide shark
tournament they're like oh it's Catch
and Release it's for science it's all
bullshit bullshit it's my chismo and
they're just trying to prove that
there's a lot more sharks out there so
they can then get it legal you know they
can then go and kill them
uh tournament uh fishing look at me uh
great white shark swim spot okay so this
is from I don't know if I don't know if
I trust this website so let me just be
careful yeah shark fishing tournament
starts protest and death threats great
let's fucking go to war so I just sent
you something Pat can you pull up the
urban legend let's do that or pull up or
can I just show you one photo so this is
what I do this is the I know what's up
my video
of a monkey uh chimpanzee so I have all
this I have to keep a lot of it private
because that's a lot of the time the
ways that I can get animals out as I
make a deal and I go hey I won't post
about this but you got to give me this
if you don't by the way you have to so I
just texted you a photo Pat this is one
of Michael Jackson's chimps in Armadillo
Texas at a roadside Zoo yeah now now
right now in prison yeah
this is one of the chubs
Jeremy and so for y'all to think of like
monkeys are so cute to have at your
parties and to have at your La kids
birthday parties and shit like that this
is what happens uh after you see them
this is what happens also a lot of horse
riding like ride horses on the beach
stuff like that go two years in a row
and see if the same horse is there the
next time Bob Dunn uh is the key to all
of it Bob Dunn uh Jane Goodall there's
actually a video of her saying to TMZ
that Michael Jackson's chimps were
abused and it was from Bob Don he's got
two drafts and boxes in Sylmar
um uh Jax is one that he was trying to
get up to Malibu wines he's super cured
Stanley and dragged Stanley around to do
Skittles commercials and all sorts of
shit he had the uh elephants for Water
for Elephants apparently on Evan
Almighty a lot of those animals just
died in transit well remember the horses
remember that um Dustin Hoffman show
about horse by the way horse racing also
the most disgusting thing look on the
fucking planet yes and it shut down
because so many horses died
um but racehorses I mean at Santa Ana
here there's 22 that died this year just
that we know of you know
they put them on they're on Adderall and
drugs and they're on fucking their knees
blow out it's absolutely they have heart
attacks if you look up horses having
heart attacks during races it's
terrifying you'll want to die it's more
it's more people than athletes during
covet and also question oh can we change
this now back yeah let's go to urban
legend and then trick or treat so we'll
talk about fun stuff yeah yeah but I
want to say one thing about cats and
that Loops into horror part of the
reason I'm terrified of cats was members
Tales from the Dark Side the episode
where the cat was chasing the guy around
and we went into his mouth in the
stomach yeah so question your
programming of like why am I scared of
this thing oh yeah when I was a kid when
I was a kid I saw that thing do
Ayahuasca and undo it whatever the fuck
you have to do smoke some weed and go oh
I was programmed with that but it's not
true by the way we were all programmed
with urban legends remember the like
obviously grew up with urban life the
best they came to me and they said you
know we're not going to continue this as
a movie series but do you want to
continue it as like an anthology TV show
and I was like I was so excited to like
pick my favorite ones like oh can I do
like the guy loses the kidney wakes up
in the bathtub full of ice and you know
someone like this you're walking through
the forest and look up and see a scuba
diver in a tree who was like in a bucket
that got dropped in a fire incredible
the girl in the white dress the person
puts on the haunted prom dress so we did
eight of them it's so fun they're on
Discovery plus awesome and Travel
Channel and this is killing it they're
doing great they're doing really they're
like I have a really good thing I have
you know goes through in my life season
two is going to come out but right now I
have uh you know well my possessed pet
will be done on the 21st and on the 28th
urban legend starts then on the 31st
around Halloween it's so Halloween I
have this thing called three ring
Inferno it's the Zach Baggins we have
the show called The Haunted Museum which
is going to come back in January so we
did a movie of he has these all he has
the largest correction collection of
haunted objects in the world at his
Museum so we just take different I think
my uterus might beat that it's one of
the Mario okay
the eggs the uterus that could be the
next show
um
anyways yeah this is why you lied I get
along we're both like if we're not
rescuing
we're making abortion jobs there's no in
between
um and so I have these shows in
Discovery plus and then in VR I shot
this VR short which was so much fun it's
a haunted house it's called trick or
treat and I mean you can look that's the
I star on it that's your uterus in the
middle
by the way that is Vanessa Hudgins
playing both parts she's never done
makeup before in her life I mean
Prosthetics and we I was like that's her
as the fairy and The Witch she's never
been evil in anything and I was like oh
and she's the queen of Halloween she
loves it she loves Halloween and she's
never been evil and she's so fantastic
in this but it's like going inside a
haunted house the whole experience is
like 15 18 minutes has the um uh we
can't say and do anything because
entertainment's not supposed to be
entertaining anymore it's supposed to
lecture and be like a Ted Talk on like
has that reached horror movies oh for
sure but here's what I'll say I was
really excited I did the Foo Fighters
horror movie studio 666 they sawed me in
half uh in a sex scene with a chainsaw
while the drummer is like fucking me
Dave gets possessed you know and he saws
me in half that's why my robot doesn't
have a body anymore I'll use your body
sacrifice beer but it was like so it was
like everyone's like okay but you know
you can wear a full bra I was like I'm
not wearing like a nursing bra and like
let's just everyone was so fucking the
intimacy coordinator thing like I get it
if you show up and you're like hey I'm
gonna be on this TV show called
Westworld and they're like here you're
in an orgy with 900 people yeah yeah and
you like I get it and you don't know
what to do or what to say and I
completely understand but the sets that
I've been on if you get a bad one they
CR like someone would be like are you
okay did they do this do they like they
come instead of saying hey we're here
for those problems you let us know
literally they won't let you send said
boundaries with that they come up to you
after and they like talk talk and they
and it's like well what about that was
that consensual like they they actually
are there they overdo it to justify
their job so there's gonna have to be a
balance however most of the actors that
I know like the beginner actors who
completely get it you want people to
feel comfortable that should be the way
the whole production should be doing the
university coordinator brought me gum
and mints oh God it's but the but the
whole idea it's just like what what are
your qualifications to like tell people
I'm like what are your qualifications
for like the coveted person like what so
I understand why we need it why you need
it and you want people to feel
comfortable but you should be doing that
anyways but if they don't here's someone
who's a neutral party but my God they
come up and they talk to and you know
I've been in scenes where there are
girls all over me like groping me or
whatever and then they'll the industry
coordinator will will come up to uh the
girls after and be like was was it okay
it's like yeah what are you talking
about I was like now you're making it
weird but there are some amazing ones
and the ones that are stunt coordinators
yeah that now are intimacy coordinators
those are amazing can I tell you so Ty
West makes X and he has an intimacy
coordinator so the film will like the
you know the guys go to make a porno
which is that and you want to do it the
intimacy coordinator was so good he
wrote the part for her and Caster as
Pearl's mother in Pearl and she'd never
acted before I haven't seen it yet but
she's a major role it's her and me a
goth she's the wicked mother and that
was the intimacy coordinator on X so
I've had the people that have had a
terrible experience and then Tai who was
like Not only was she cool Not only was
she awesome and everyone loved her and
it really made everything go easy I
wrote the part for her and cast her in
my next movie that's incredible and I
think a lot of people so if you get that
it's great it depends who you get it
depends like anything yeah so that kind
of wokeness has definitely hit horror
movies and you hear it from the studios
you hear it in casting and I'm just like
I always want to like do what's best for
the movie and cast the best person and
cast this and sometimes you can feel
when the suggestions come from that
place and the people often suggesting it
don't even believe it it's like they
have a script of what they have to say
on a zoom in front of others
so that they don't get fired and once
you sort of get that and you can distill
like is really this actually what you
want because this doesn't make any sense
for the part that we're casting but why
are you forcing this idea and they go
well yeah you're right we tried okay
that's fine we don't have to do it but
they have to bring up the discussion
about it so my thing is horror should
always be shocking and provoking and fun
and not not like you not like not you
don't want to be tone deaf right you you
can be offensive but not being like
there's tone deaf is like a different
quality it's just like yeah did you not
think of that yeah and and you didn't
address it in a clever way but when it's
like when you said when you make a
horribly offensive joke it better be
more funny than it is offensive and when
you do a horror movie it better be
fucking smart and the kills better be
great because if you're just being
offensive to be offensive I think people
are a little bored of that yes and you
know look we're the same way in comedy
it's like doing a joke that's already
been done it's like it's just unoriginal
well comedy has gotten so stale and so
safe it makes me so sad that you were
just in our writer's room though like
it's all right it's good and by the way
there were a lot of people that feel
that way that because because what it
does is infinite it infantilizes the
audience it's like it treats everyone
like a little child who can't hear a bad
word and can't discern between a joke
like you're telling me as an adult I'm
too stupid to understand the difference
between satire and that when I used to
do I used to do these like rape jokes
that I still stand behind you know it's
like whatever like I was something you
know I got back when I did more like
one-liners in the beginning of like the
key to never get raped is just like
don't say no like I just like I just
don't say no it's like I'm unraveable
like or some people women would come up
to me after shows with like tears in
their eyes and they're like thank you
for making me laugh about that I've
never been able to laugh about it
whatever and then I would I would have
guys tell me or be like you can't make
rape jokes like I mean the people that
the people that are so offended I was
like but you're not the audience I
watched an entire room of white
Executives tell a black director that he
had to hire a diverse person for a role
oh by the way I've I've seen it where
there's an Asian person they're like
well we're all white here in the room we
need some diversity and the Asian
person's like
um and they're like oh yeah I know we
mean I was like I was like so we're not
diverse enough and then they're like
well
we need more diversity it's like well
they're gay well does that it's like
what's your scorecard guys yeah
someone's fully black are they more or
half or is that half diverse like it's
actually amazing and then they go you
can't even ask that question because
that question's too like I'll report it
to HR basically it's become a power play
to of I can get you fired that's right
none of this is about protection it's a
citizen's arrest like it's this work
this is they can't get power any other
way this is about control
why are you telling a it's someone of
color what it is you know it is it all
feeds into the and I read read Atlas
shrugs and The Fountainhead einrand is
my favorite writer I've read her
philosophy I've read I went I did more
and I did Anthem Fountainhead Atlas
shark the pandemic I was like 1984
Animal Farm Anthem Fountainhead Atlas
Shrugged and I was like oh yeah we are
repeating Atlas Shrug that's right Ein
Rand is all about like you shouldn't be
ashamed of aspiring to Greatness and
achieving it that's what that's how
skyscrapers are built that's how we
achieve our highest selves and what
we're capable of is by being the best
and when you do that and then someone's
like you only had that because of this I
don't have it because either they don't
have the talent or they don't work hard
or life is dealt in machine shitty hand
or whatever it's a way of trying to turn
the tables of Power with its nonsense
not by whoever is achieving the greatest
so what it is I think is people that
have hijacked a good cause I don't
believe it starts there and it's
performative I don't think it starts
there I think it starts from people that
are really upset or being like well this
is really fucked up like oh here's
another show with five white people like
I get it like I understand where it
comes from but I think it very quickly
gets co-opted and hijacked by people
that can turn it into a power struggle I
can get you fired for this and I'm gonna
get the bag I'm gonna make money off
this and here's what I'll say uh in my
experience in this sort of like new
thing is that the people that are the
most yeah when you point a finger at
someone you point three at yourself so
it's like it's always the people that
have like skeletons in their closet you
know remember when that guy uh the who
was the New York Police Commissioner
Eric Schneider maybe who took like a a
press
initiated a press conference that nobody
asked for just to say how bad of a
person Harvey Weinstein was because
yeah he had like punched two women in
the neck like actually crazy it was like
wild it's like the men that wear a shirt
that says feminist you're like I would
like to see your dance feminist yeah
yeah and also who look at the designer
that's a male designer who's making
money off of you pretending to be a
feminist you know they doth protest too
much yeah exactly you know and I think
that this um uh yeah this performative
activism has gone like completely by the
way when we did Green Inferno when I
shot that 10 years ago and the kids are
holding signs saying the janitors clean
up after the one percent they just go to
the Amazon to save a tribe just to
fucking be the top trending to be
trending on Twitter to get on Reddit for
the phones they don't care they just all
they care about are the photos and then
they get fucking their plane crashes and
the people they're treated as Invaders
and they're fucking chopped up and eat
and become the food supply then they're
begging for the bulldozers to show up to
tear down the village to rescue them
it's all about that and we thought we
were going too far we're like well no
one's this ridiculous and it's amazing
how prescient it was like you can't
we're like oh my God we actually now you
look at it so Tim we didn't go far
enough yeah with how crazy people go
with this stuff and but I get it it's
like people want it's an easy way of
getting instant recognition without
doing the work and and yeah a lot of
people ask me for advice of being a
director and you know it's they think
that because they watch movies they can
just walk on a set and know what to do
and it's like I've been doing this for
30 years now being on sets like I
understand and you have to put in the
time like now I'm entering that phase
where I walk on the set I know when
people are lying I know when they're not
doing a job I know how to do it just
like you with being a comedian you can't
just be like I'm funny I make jokes I
make my friends laugh I'm gonna go have
a podcast I'm going to start like what
you have accomplished from sitting down
every day and writing down every funny
thought you had and pushing and pushing
and pushing and I remember like driving
I have a very vivid memory of driving
down Hollywood Boulevard and all along
things just said Whitney Whitney Whitney
Whitney and it was like Hollywood and
Highland and they were spending 20
million like Millions on your show
campaign yeah my biggest campaigner show
and I was like holy shit Whitney fucking
made it good for her this is I was so
happy because remember that's on the
treadmill fucking with each other at the
gym and I was like she did it and then
it didn't really have your voice and at
all and I was like oh this is it you're
getting shoehorned in and I was like
this is actually the worst thing that
could happen because now most people
think that she is this and that you
fucking rebuilt it from scratch just
actually literally using your voice
putting the cameras in the room saying
whatever the fuck you want and putting
it directly to your fans and now
Hollywood is beating down the door
begging you to work with them to be
yourself but you had to go through that
experience of like doing the stand-up
blah blah better having that fucking
crushing humiliation of people going
this show isn't funny and you're like
but this isn't even my like it gets
taken away from you it's so far away
from you they took all my tweets like uh
and for the
um like tag they marketed it as a like a
shitty sitcom from the 80s like I was
like please don't put this up please
like it was it looked like Veronica's
Closet it was like cursive and I was
like No And I had never done you know I
was like also made to be so annoying
like I know I was uh
marketing executive's idea of what I
tested I test very highly yeah so I
tested really well and the pilot tested
you know through the room that's right I
test shitty and everything so I know
it's gonna work I test the fucking
garbage House of Cards well tested well
and Death Wish was the highest testing
movie mgmer had and there was like
two shootings before it came out
unfortunately I mean obviously not for
the movie for other reasons I remember
that but you know hostile was cabin
fever's lowest testing movie in the
history of Lionsgate if you're supposed
to get 100 is a good score we got a 19.
hostile 33 34 because they're divisive
because you're supposed to be like I
know many people shitty and people come
out and they're like how do you feel
would I recommend it no why because I
don't feel good recommending this to my
friends they don't like this kind of
stuff but it doesn't matter but also I
used to um do uh when I was broke had I
married you maybe I had to have a little
more money earlier um but uh I'll still
be making jokes we would have
accomplished nothing
um I forgot what I was in there well
yeah we're talking about uh oh when I
was broke I used to do focus groups uh
for products for Neutrogena stuff like
that like I've been in focus groups I
know and they go like what did you not
like about it and just to be asked back
I would just feel like I had to answer
I'd be like oh well I didn't really like
like the well they want to say something
to to make a comment like people don't
like this character what guy is the
villain yeah what did you not like about
this character they think if they take
away everything unlikable but that's the
death of interesting Cinema and then you
see independent movies that come out and
the people are like really people
respond to authenticity well Larry David
like by the way smile I mean smile was
gonna go straight to video and they
tested it and they put it out and it's
gonna make 100 million dollars
incredible I work on this no joke about
like or I did it a while ago but it's
like I'm trying to redo it now that
smile is out of like when men Heckle you
on the street like smile smile it's just
like you know how weird it would be if I
was just like walking down the street
just like like it would be you know yeah
exactly it's so you don't want me to
just be smiling all the time there's
nothing creepier than that you know
um but uh can I just ask you like speed
round you have to leave soon yeah uh
favorite horror movie like what was the
one that yeah I know it's probably
online somewhere it doesn't have to be
favorite just like mine is basket case
basket is the Masterpiece yes you know
I'm obsessed with baskets I'm obsessed
with basket case it's it's a brilliant
film there's a beautiful 4K restoration
on the Arrow channel of basket our
channel is my favorite chat it's like if
you subscribe our Channel Arrow channel
is incredible it might be on shutter as
well but okay where you can see history
of horror
um Basket Case Frank hennen Lotter I
like Basket Case too Hannah lotteries
are really really he did good Joe Bob
Briggs episode where if you've seen
frankenhooker yes it really holds up yes
yes she looks at Franklin okay Frank and
hooker really really holds up yeah
fucking hen and Ladder was my favorite
and Jeffrey Lorenz or from
yeah done done okay okay so basket case
I watch Basket Case okay yeah I saw a
basket case when I was a kid the two VHS
tapes I rented that night were basket
case and pieces
let me just say let me put pieces out
there is my favorite horror film that's
wild pieces is the most fun you'll ever
have watching a movie I don't want to
ruin it it was an openly gay director in
Spain in like 1982 Juan BK Simon and the
whole movie is clearly about his sort of
issues with repressed sexuality it's
amazing the best fucking slasher movie I
mean it's literally like the girl walks
in the elevator and the guy's like
hiding the chainsaw and it's like oh hi
I didn't know you were you were here and
pulls it out and then they're like
there's some amazing desks because it
shows it and Paul uh Paul L Smith who
played Pluto and Popeye is in it just
giving the stink eye it's a great who
done it like slash you're trying to
guess who the Killer is with Ian Sarah
is Kendall who starred and there was
like uh a Mac and Me ripoff with him and
trumpy the Elephant of trump they have a
trumpy the alien there's there's a Mac
there's an E.T rip-off called
extraterrestrial Invaders that came out
from the same director actor combo of
pieces want to be care someone he also
made a movie called slugs but but if you
watch pieces the Ian Sarah want because
where there's an alien and the alien's
name is trumpy it's called
extraterrestrial visitors
Sublime rip-off Spanish cinema I also
love uh movies that are horror movies by
accident oh yeah like I love uh uh lost
in La Mancha about Terry Gilliam trying
to make uh oh it's called man of the
month just last in the Munch right oh
lost in the matcha and is trying to make
this movie
it's like if anyone in production is the
hardest thing to watch everything that
could go wrong goes wrong like to the
point where like okay the actor that's
playing Don Quixote like he all he has
to do is sit on a horse he gets
testicular cancer a right or prostate
cancer and they're like the only thing
you can't do is sit on a horse like it
is just and then they sets blow down oh
yeah well there's a flood they lose all
their cameras but then also they they're
shooting in this desert so these rains
come so the clay and the sand is now
dark and it doesn't match any of what
they did and they have to wait for the
sand to dry for like four months it's
like Fitz the costume trailer caught on
fire and it was all these gorgeous
costumes like it's stuff like I love
like things that are horror movies to
you if it's something you do for a
living yeah that's definitely no lost
and low I was I remember we had a test
screening of cabin fever or there was
like a screening of something and then
we like started and I went in the
theater next door and went lost in the
launch and it's like a q a after and I
was so depressed I was like deeply
rattled by that film um may I ask are
there any movies you wish you made or
would want to remake oh my god well the
movies that you wish you made
like what if I had made Caddyshack or
something like that you know like a
mastery's like like or The Blues
Brothers to just drive through a
shopping mall or jump the bridges yeah
those are the movies that got me excited
or like what if I had made the Texas
Chainsaw Massacre what was it like to be
there and I talked to Toby hoop or God
Rest his soul about what it was like
making that movie being on that set
going insane in the 110 degree heat
filming like the meat rotting on the
table and this like everyone's just
going insane making that film
um
but yeah I mean it's like the movies
that I wanted to remake
are the movies that I left the theater
I've got to that age where I started
being mad that I spent money on a movie
so I was like I really want to remake
Caddyshack too you know that back to
school I know who owns the rights to
back to school Rodney Dangerfield well
back yeah well back to school I think
was fine yeah Keith Gordon Rodney danger
the triple Lindy mm at Walsh I don't
have like a deep desire to remake back
yeah yeah I mean I thought Sam Kinison
was fantastic in back to school but
weirdly Sam Kinison back to school and
police academy 2 came out right right
Bobcat Goldthwait and Sam Kinison broke
at the same time in a movie and
everyone's like you know the guy who
screams and back to school it's like
that's the guy from Police Academy too
it's like no it's not the guy from
Police Academy two isn't the guy from
back to school that's you know it was
crazy
um and then also basically Los Angeles
has turned into Police Academy too
that's where all the police
basically there's no police in Bobcat
Goldthwait it's like
my nipples are hurting also one of my
favorite accidental horror movies for me
is a bobcat golf weight joint called
Windy City Heat where you are that is
the best movie I think the I think the
funniest movie I've ever seen yeah I
make it that's like my test can I be
friends with you can we talk about and
can I date you first I just need you to
watch Danny I need to watch Windy City
Heat and let if you don't get it if you
don't get Windy City Heat there's
nothing I've had a lot of guys be like
this looks this is me no I met John
Barris and I was like I was completely
Star Struck By The Big Three I have a
big three t-shirt I'm like fully you
know the man the Van Nuys Film Festival
everything about that movie is it
flawless flawless
on set huh I go and I
Act
I don't say action I say because that's
what Bobcat does I did that on my last
film I would say that and remember when
he took the phone call with Barry there
and he goes it's the president of Show
Business yeah it's like a short call
it's the greatest
Hiroshima Nagasaki is coming don't touch
the donuts MO
it's just like did you see the episode
where he went on Kimmel for the premiere
he went to the premiere and went on
Kimmel because Kimmel was a cruiser on
it too I like forgot that that even
happened genius Perry is like uh um
tweets about me kind of constantly oh
that's good yeah I know
I know I'm kind of like weirdly
Starstruck but I don't know if I should
have him on the podcast yeah America's
Sweethearts accidental horror movie
Billy Crystal and Julia Roberts
interesting people are like if you could
relive your life like if you could do
anything over I would do I was like I
would do everything exactly as I did it
except for the two hours where I watched
America's Sweethearts oh is that the one
with um Catherine Zeta Jones it's it's
Julia Roberts and Billy Crystal where
he's like a publicist trying to it's
like it's my it's good giant I mean I'm
sorry oh yeah Catherine Zeta Jones is in
this as her sister or the the celebrity
that she assists or something it was
just so it was just not my favorite
movie yeah tricky I don't know
um by the way irreversible is one of
changed my life
the gas fire is amazing is that Gaspar
it changed no it's incredible it changed
climax
no oh it's so good so yeah I saw it when
I went to I Stand Alone climax have you
seen love yes incredible but but
irreversible it's it's it is the hard a
tough watch but it changed the way that
I perceived time and appreciated my time
because you see it it's told completely
in Reverse yeah so you see the horrible
shit at the end that happened isn't it
three takes the whole movie three or
four takes
I don't know I think it's like three or
four takes you see the horrible thing uh
and you see the couple fighting before
the before the thing horrible thing
happened and then you see them just
being boring as couple and you're like
like it's it made me appreciate look at
time differently and stop wasting it it
made me make different decisions I'm
just checking to see how fucked I am for
my next appointment I'm so sorry no no I
just want to make sure that I need to be
honest and then are you on Wi-Fi
good for you I am supposed to be on a
zoom at four um 357 from home so if you
leave now no I have to go to it anyways
do are you gonna go back yeah I'm not
gonna tell you I have to go uh sound mix
trick or treat which is out now in meta
Quest Horizon worlds and metaquest TV
obsessed obsessed obsessed it's so fun I
sing it in VR you're like in the haunted
house it's really cool yeah you do need
one of those headsets but that's kind of
the fun of it I have a billion more um
questions for you not today not today we
might have to do a round two I'm gonna
force you to come back I'm gonna force
you to do one of our of course
um it's I'm in it's now time in Holland
for women to force men to do things I I
men Force themselves on me I've forced
men to do my podcast it's not really a
force if I agree to you if I just say
if I just say yes you're on I'm
unforceable
this NDA is unenforceable also
um I love you so much I end these very
awkwardly I don't want to disrespect
your time
someone let you go I thought that was it
amazing I thought it was like unseen no
I I do have to go mix the thing okay I'm
talking about elephants
um don't kill sharks shark free go to a
future with sharks.com go on Discovery
plus and watch Finn if you want to learn
more yes you can watch all my other
shows on there I want to do a screening
here follow Eli Roth presents for that
stuff go to metaquest trick or treat and
you know just try and
not each shark let me ask you is there a
connection between uh global warming uh
or climate change whatever you guys
believe in whatever and the killing of
sharks
there's no question that when you throw
the ocean that out of balance something
is off I'm not I'm not a scientist I
could not prove that but we are proving
that you as you're seeing these algae
blooms spreading and reefs dying reefs
like the yellow Suns reefs without
sharks keeping things in balance that
are producing our oxygen obviously
things are things are messed up and we
and we don't have the grass trapping
carbon the seagrass because we're
killing all the tiger sharks so the
turtles are overpopulated like when
things are out of balance the planet
can't naturally heal itself so what do
and the problem is it like when they say
going to cities to get things listed as
threatened and endangered there's so
much money behind the fishing industry
to keep things going the way they are it
is entirely an industry so anytime you
see a shark out of the water someone's
making money so and also something needs
to happen because the dolphin safe tuna
thing that like worked you know
there needs to be shark safe we're going
to do that the time we're working with
shark allies I'm going to partner with
them we're going to start a shark free
label I'm working with Emma they started
non-GMO they're like they're they're
great so I there's a great app where you
can um uh make sure that things are
actually not used uh animal products
aren't used in it where you can like run
the barcode but we'll make sure we have
to make sure that sharks uh is involved
in that yeah have you tried the
impossible Panda Burger it tastes just
like real panda
sorry
and we make sure it's not just on him I
love you guys don't ride elephants um
you know what to do uh I promise I will
have Eli back and I will ask all the
questions that you guys sent that we
didn't get to you can yell at me at real
Eli Roth on Instagram
if people want to go after me real Eli
Ross no they'll love you because
um uh you don't let me interrupt you
everything will love you
okay I love you guys don't ride elephant
[Music]
[Applause]